The TV series based on the works of Stephen
King are a mixed bag.
Some are incredible; others, not so much.
So which ones are worth watching?
We're leaving out some big ones here, counting
only the TV series or miniseries with three
or more installments.
With that in mind, here's every Stephen King
TV series ranked from worst to best.
Stephen King has long been outspoken of his
contempt for Stanley Kubrick's 1980 adaptation
of The Shining.
In 2014, he told Rolling Stone that he considered
it not only a terrible adaptation, but a bad
movie in general.
He explained:
"Obviously people absolutely love it, and
they don't understand why I don't.
The book is hot, and the movie is cold; the
book ends in fire, and the movie in ice."
King took particular aim at how the movie
adapted the Wendy character, played with desperate
intensity by Shelley Duvall.
The writer said of her portrayal,
"It’s so misogynistic.
I mean, Wendy Torrance is just presented as
this sort of screaming dishrag."
Kubrick's adaptation of The Shining wouldn't
be the last.
17 years later, ABC released a three-episode
miniseries version of the story, starring
Steven Weber and Rebecca de Mornay.
Over four and a half hours, King was able
to finally give audiences the story he always
wanted to see on-screen.
While it was reviewed well at the time, the
years haven't been very kind to it.
"There you are, Doc.
Been looking for you.
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA.”
Turns out, four and a half hours is far too
much for this particular King story.
The series drags, feeling bloated to fill
time, and Weber plays crazy in a way that's
more goofy than frightening.
The whole thing plays out like an overcorrection,
and it winds up being far worse than anything
Kubrick could've ever produced.
The 2002 series Rose Red revolves around a
dormant, haunted Seattle mansion.
Psychology professor Joyce Reardon brings
in an unsuspecting group of would-be psychics
to serve as bait for the house so she can
somehow get back at her department chair for
taking her tenure.
Aside from the house itself, which makes for
a decent horror backdrop, everything else
about Rose Red falls totally flat.
Too much time is wasted on wandering about
aimlessly, calling out to each other, and…
well, wandering some more.
The characters are awful stereotypes, and
Nancy Travis is horribly miscast as Joyce.
All in all, this miniseries feels more like
a wilted rose than a red one.
Stephen King's Golden Years was actually the
first original piece of work the author created
for TV.
Airing on CBS in 1991, the series centered
around Harlan Williams, a janitor in his 70s
who is given strange powers after a lab experiment
goes awry.
Harlan is doused in chemicals that not only
reverse his aging but, in later episodes,
give him powers that affect the world around
him.
In spite of its supernatural overtones, Golden
Years winds up playing out a lot like a typical
political thriller.
The onset of Harlan's powers means that he
has to keep hidden from government agents
who worry their top secret experiments will
somehow be exposed.
Harlan is a threat, so he has to figure out
not only how to keep the agency bad guys off
his tail, but also how to reverse the effects
of his chemical accident.
While it may not be the best thing King has
ever made, it's at least entertaining for
the most part.
Luckily, the show is also supported by one
of the better casts to have appeared in a
Stephen King series, too.
Haven ran on Syfy for five seasons between
2010 and 2015, which actually makes it one
of Stephen King's most commercially successful
TV series.
Based on the author's novel The Colorado Kid,
Haven follows FBI agent Audrey Parker as she
investigates supernatural occurrences called
the "Troubles" in Haven, Maine.
As time goes on, the show delves deeper into
Audrey's mysterious backstory, as well as
the source of the Troubles.
Haven took some time to find its footing,
and its first season was the lowest rated
of its five on Rotten Tomatoes, with the critics'
consensus being that the show was a "derivative
supernatural crime procedural."
As time went on, however, Haven improved,
shifting focus onto its supernatural elements
and character development rather than following
the standard police procedural formula.
The show can go a little off the rails at
times, but as a whole, it works pretty well.
Nightmares & Dreamscapes: From the Stories
of Stephen King is an eight-part anthology
series that ran on TNT in 2006.
It's based mostly off King's short story collection
of the same name, and each episode tells a
completely different tale, with a completely
different cast of actors.
In true King fashion, Nightmares & Dreamscapes
acts as a near perfect representation of the
author's track record with small screen adaptations.
Some of the episodes are good.
Others are not.
The biggest problem is that Nightmares & Dreamscapes
tries to do a little bit of everything, which
perhaps explains why it winds up finding success
only about half the time.
What it does manage to do well, however, is
bring together a solid cast for each episode
— and the presence of those casts tends
to make up for some of the show's weaker storylines.
Overall, however, Nightmares & Dreamscapes
only serves as a sad reminder that you could
be spending your time watching a much better
anthology series.
In a perfect world, Kingdom Hospital would
have been a miniseries.
Instead, it was stretched into a regular TV
show that still wound up lasting only 15 episodes.
It tells the story of the bizarre staff and
patients at Kingdom Hospital in Lewiston,
Maine, a place that sits on the ruins of another,
recently burned-down hospital.
The show gets pretty crazy at times, but it's
also genuinely creepy, too.
By far the most interesting thing about Kingdom
Hospital, however, is the fact that it's the
first adaptation Stephen King took on that
wasn't drawn from his own material.
In fact, the show was originally based on
a Danish TV movie by Lars von Trier.
Still, King told The New York Times that the
show was
"...the thing I like best out of all the things
I've done."
The Mist could've been a great show about
human nature and the horror that comes with
facing your deepest secrets.
Instead, it goes way too far with its visual
effects and totally forgets that in order
to make an audience care about a character,
that character has to be likable.
"I think we should think less and pray more."
In the case of The Mist, which only made it
to ten episodes before being cancelled, the
characters are generally pretty terrible people,
and they really don't make it easy to root
for them.
Add to that across-the-board mediocrity on
the part of the show's actors, and the result
is a series that fails to live up to the big-screen
version that came a few years before.
On the plus side, The Mist does have one of
the creepiest settings of any Stephen King
adaptation.
The fictional Bridgeville, Maine, is a beautiful
and picturesque location that morphs into
a living nightmare for its residents.
Apart from that?
Not much to see, here.
In 1999, ABC aired Storm of the Century, a
three-part miniseries about the residents
of Little Tall Island, set off the coast of
Maine.
When a storm rolls in that brings the town
to a complete standstill, a mysterious and
deadly man named André Linoge approaches
the townspeople and promises not to harm them,
for a price.
In a sinister twist, that price turns out
to be one of the families' children.
Storm of the Century is another of Stephen
King's original screenplays, as opposed to
an adapted work, and while it's a far more
successful attempt at the danger-in-the-weather
theme than that portrayed by The Mist, its
failure lies in King's inability to self-edit.
There's really no reason this particular story
should've been a three-part series.
If anything, it would've made a great feature
film.
But there's only so far you can go with the
story of a demonic man in search of a protégé,
especially when the bulk of people involved
in the story are pretty one-dimensional background
characters.
Under the Dome has a fascinating premise.
An entire town is suddenly blocked off from
the rest of the world by way of a huge, indestructible
dome.
No one knows where it came from, the government
can't get through it, and resources quickly
start to dwindle.
While there are sci-fi elements obviously
in place here, Under the Dome finds its most
success on account of Stephen King's ability
to find monsters in everyday people.
Its first season was certified fresh on Rotten
Tomatoes, with the critics' consensus being
that the show was:
"...an effective and engrossing horror/mystery
with airtight plotting and great special effects."
But like other King series, Under the Dome
lost steam going into its second and third
seasons.
Despite a number of twists and turns in the
story, there just wasn't enough story there
to warrant the number of years it stayed on
the air.
Like many of Stephen King's stories, The Dead
Zone begins with a car crash.
After waking up from a six-year coma, Johnny
Smith suddenly becomes able to see the past
and future of those he comes into contact
with.
As The Dead Zone progresses, Johnny becomes
more involved with law enforcement, taking
on an advisory role of sorts to help solve
crimes.
This was in 2002, prior to Haven and so many
other supernatural crime dramas we see on
TV now — so at the time, The Dead Zone was
a fairly original concept.
Add to that a solid cast, and the show winds
up being a pretty well-rounded endeavor for
its six season run.
If you were to flip on The Stand now, there's
a good chance you wouldn't be able to make
it through the first episode.
The special effects in this six-hour miniseries
are very, very bad, firmly cementing it in
time as a product of early '90s television.
If you can look past its dodgy effects, however,
The Stand is a series that won't disappoint.
The Stand follows the journey of a group of
survivors in post-apocalyptic America.
This series is a long haul, too — it's a
four-part miniseries that completely lays
out and then resolves the battle for humanity.
But so is the Stephen King novel it's based
upon — at over 1100 pages, The Stand is
one of the author's longest books.
Ultimately, the miniseries does the work justice,
but it'll take a little sacrifice on the viewer's
part to get there.
In 2016, Stephen King teamed up with J.J.
Abrams to bring his novel 11/22/63 to life.
The resulting series, which ran for eight
episodes on Hulu, tells the story of what
would happen if someone prevented JFK's assassination.
James Franco plays Jake Epping, a teacher
who discovers a time portal in the back room
of his friend's cafe.
"I’m telling ya.
You shouldn't be here.”
“Well...
I'm here."
As Jake attempts to change the past, the past
pushes back against his efforts, and things
get complicated when he meets and falls for
a woman named Sadie.
Not only is this a Stephen King series that
doesn't look like a cheap, made-for-TV movie,
but 11.22.63 is also well-acted and well-written,
and its eight episode length is exactly the
right amount of time to tell this story without
it feeling like it's dragging audiences into
the abyss.
Everything that Stephen King does best all
comes together beautifully in the little Maine
town of Castle Rock.
In the creepy Hulu show of the same name,
André Holland plays Henry Matthew Deaver,
a man who returns to his hometown two decades
after leaving, having once been suspected
of killing his adopted father.
During his stay, he uncovers some disturbing
secrets buried by the town's officials, as
well as the supernatural forces behind them.
Castle Rock has ties to the wider world of
King's written work, so fans will continually
come across hidden Easter eggs and in-universe
nods.
But more importantly, the series is just really
well done.
The cast is phenomenal, the production value
is high, and the result is a genuinely frightening
show that has introduced new generations to
the twisty, terrifying world of America's
greatest horror author.
Mr. Mercedes premiered on the Audience network
in 2017.
The series tells the story of Bill Hodges,
a retired detective determined to solve the
case of "Mr. Mercedes," a killer who took
the lives of 16 people at a local job fair.
When Mr. Mercedes sets his sights on Hodges,
a dark and twisted game of cat and mouse ensues.
The show walks a fine line between police
drama, mystery, and horror, and the further
along it gets into its narrative, the more
sinister the plot becomes.
Its premiere season is certified fresh on
Rotten Tomatoes, with the critics' consensus
being that it:
"...propels its tense, creepy narrative with
quick-witted dialogue, strong characters,
and terrifying surprises."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.